in machine learning
one of the best ways to learn more about
your data is by classifying it with what
you already know
you can group together a bunch of data
based on similar characteristics
because you already know these
characteristics you can classify the
data using supervised machine learning
a very common supervised machine
learning algorithm for multi-class
classification is k-nearest neighbor
this is an instance-based machine
learning algorithm
or what's also called lazy learning with
lazy learning
the bulk of the computation happens
right before you want to classify your
data
the learning doesn't happen continuously
instead
you run all your computation in one big
instance
in a sense you're saving up all your
energy for one big splash
k n compares something you don't know to
what you already have
so in some ways you're getting
immediately rewarded for the size and
quality of your training data
the downside is that this takes a lot of
computational power so sometimes it's
difficult to use k n on very large data
sets
think of it this way for a veterinary
doctor
one of the most difficult jobs was
trying to classify the breed of each new
dog
there are hundreds of different known
dog breeds
not only that the dogs aren't that
close-minded about who they breed with
so you have a lot of mixed breeds
each time when there is a new dog the
veterinary doctor would hold it up to
several of the existing dogs that were
already classified
then we'd look at some of the
characteristics
maybe it was the shape of their face or
the color of their hair
in a sense the purpose was trying to
classify the unknown dog by looking for
its nearest neighbor
another way to look at it is you're
trying to minimize the distance between
the unknown dog and the known breeds
if the characteristics were closely
matched then there was a very short
distance between the unknown dog
and its nearest neighbor
minimizing the distance is a key part of
k-nearest neighbor
the closer you are to your nearest
neighbors the more likely you are to be
accurate
the most common way to do this is
through something called euclidean
distance
there is a pretty sophisticated
mathematical formula that can help see
the distance between your different data
points
now imagine you had millions of dogs and
you wanted to classify them based on
their breed
to start out we might want to create two
key characteristics
these will help you classify dogs that
share the same breed
these are often called predictors so
let's use their weight and the length of
their hair
now let's take these two characteristics
and put them on an x y
axis diagram let's put the length of
their hair along the y
axis and their weight along the x-axis
let's take 1 000 classified dogs in our
training set
we'll put them on the graph based on
their weight and hair length
now let's take our unknown dog and put
it in the same chart
you can see that it's not matched with
another dog but it has a bunch of close
neighbors
let's say we use a k of five that means
we'd want to put a circle around our
unclassified
dog and its five closest neighbors you
can see that if the distance of the
other dogs is shorter
you'll probably get a much more accurate
classification
now let's look at the five closest
neighbors
you'll see that three of them are
huskies and two of them are shepherds
you can be somewhat confident to
classify your unknown dog as a husky
k nearest neighbor is a very common and
powerful machine learning algorithm
that's because it can do more than just
sort dogs
in fact it's commonly used in finance to
look for the best stocks
and even predict future performance
you